let's talk about this story we got right
here from from the post-millennial
cnn plans to create team dedicated to
covering misinformation oh good do you
feel like you have to jump down every
rabbit hole you see do you get mad when
you see liars taking advantage of people
i do like jake tapper and brian stelter
and um i don't even i don't even what's
this guy's name acosta
costa
he no that's that's not him he's so
irrelevant i forgot the guy's name
but these people
lie
non-stop
then they go on their tv channel that's
that's dropped in ratings by ninety
percent and they're they're yeah
reliable sources i think i love the
irony of the name right imagine imagine
a fire department called like flaming
fire truck you'd be like
that i don't know if i'd want them to
come at the fire but the fire is free
tim a fire truck on fire
is the best way to explain what reliable
sources on cnn means it is one of the
least reliable sources and now they're
going to be telling us that they're
making this you know anti-disinformation
show alex koppelman says some very
exciting media jobs tell you i'm hiring
three people for a new cnn team
dedicated to covering misinformation
throughout the team and job starts here
please feel free to share far and wide
and if you're interested reach out or
apply at the links you know
part of me is frustrated that we talk
about cnn because when i learned that
their ratings were down by over 90 and
they were getting between like 70 and
100 000 in the key demo i was like wow
we should just not talk about them
anymore because they're irrelevant
but they still do have institutional
authority youtube props them up puts
them on the front page and then you get
100 million plus youtube views so we
need to make sure we're calling out all
of the lies and manipulations from cnn
this is like ian doing anti-drug
commercials
this makes no sense at all this is like
the ultimate epitome of hypocrisy that
we have to deal with cnn being fact
checkers are you kidding me like i mean
what kind of parallel universe are we
living in where they think they could
pull this off i mean they have no
credibility they have been lying to the
american people non-stop 24 7
fear-mongering and and they're losing
the audience because the audience
understands like hey i don't want to be
spoken down to i don't want to have my
thoughts controlled i don't want to have
my perspectives limited to what you want
me to think they're the perfect
representatives they're pr for the
special ruling elite and they're nothing
else but that i'm i get uh angrier and
angrier you know seeing what these
people do and uh maybe there's a lot of
people who who watch them don't
understand why i would be so like you
know so so so pissed off at the things
cnn does or msnbc and you know just
watching rachel maddow on the verge of
tears when the russiagate scandal was
proven the russiagate thing was proven
false she was almost crying i think i i
totally understand why so many people
were laughing and so happy to see that
pain schadenfreude to see these evil
people lie
for now now i've been doing it forever
you know but it's gotten so bad
and for the the nerve of these people to
to just keep pushing the lies like uh
cuomo chris cuomo
faked being in quarantine
we all know it and they still keep lying
what pisses me off is that people keep
falling for it well i didn't fall for
this bit when you look at this picture
of these dudes i see airbrushed
photography really bright light coming
from the left shadow on the right to
make him give this angelic glow it just
it just oozes with with crap well it's
so actually that's jake tapper on the
left right yeah i feel really sad about
jake tapper because i remember during
the obama years he confronted i want to
say jake
what he was the least bad yeah he
confronted jay carney i think it was
about the kill list about obama's kill
list and he was really forceful about it
i think it's probably still on youtube
and then fast forward to the trump years
and he's having a tantrum meltdown
because donald trump didn't thank john
mccain in the nbaa spending bill are you
going to talk about indefinite detention
built into that bill you're going to
talk about the billions of dollars spent
on empire no no he's going to thank john
mccain for his service because donald
trump didn't and it's just so sad to
watch i wonder about that too like you
know we get wrapped up in so much as
culture war stuff even talking about cnn
i wonder if that's what keeps us safe on
youtube because if we started talking
about the ndaa indefinite detention
provision and obama and biden killing
kids and the corruption and we start
getting deep on foreign policy i bet
then they would nuke us yeah that would
be an example of not playing ball right
now we're actually playing tennis with
cnn talking about how bad they are we're
keeping them prescient but uh and
relevant by talking about them yeah but
i do wonder like who do they think this
is for like benefit of the doubt they
just have poor strategy and they think
that they're going to actually reach
people mired in disinformation like
benefit of the doubt they're really
doing they think they're being really
honorable journalists and they're trying
to stop the spread of misinformation but
in reality who's going to watch this
it's people who already agree with them
so that kind of just serves intentional
or not to deepen the divide and deepen
the polarization where the people
watching the show can be like ah look at
those idiots look how stupid they are
that they would believe that i'm better
than them they're other than me and all
that really does is perpetuate the
division that's already so severe can
you tell me the difference between
misinformation and disinformation one is
accidental one's intentional yeah what's
intentional offhand
misinformation is
when people are just wrong and
disinformation i may have used that
incorrectly or interchangeably but yeah
i'm looking at this digital digital
forensic research lab from the atlantic
council and they're they're out to study
disinformation and expose falsehoods
intentional propaganda
that's what we were doing intentional
propaganda disinformation that's the
cia's main
main
opera operation modus operandi is
disinformation right and what's so funny
is with the anti-media for example it
was our strategy to as often as possible
cite mainstream news just to set what
are you gonna say we're quoting you and
if you dig into a lot of those
mainstream articles the information is
there they just don't lead with it they
don't emphasize it it's you know it's a
byline or a scrolling marquee on it on a
tv channel but it's the most of that
information is out there the new york
times was reporting on obama's killers
during the obama years it's not that
they're not covering it it's just it's
not propped up and blasted and it's not
forced into the the biggest narrative
that they're pushing let me ask you guys
a question don't look at the screen
all right we'll start with uh with you
carrie
cnn 11 p.m slot
how many viewers in the key demo do you
think don lemon got
what's the key demo 25 to 54.
i mean
major cable network cnn they're in
hotels how many key demo viewers you
think they would get
generously
75 000. i don't know you're cheating
because that's that's 74. oh is it
really nothing like how nice yeah i
didn't look i swear that's one day msnbc
11th hour how many how many how many
think they got the key
demo fifty thousand eight thousand
eighty five thousand eighty and then gut
felt on fox news
two hundred three hundred and forty
three thousand
so if you if you look at their ratings
in general with the older crowd it's a
bit higher i think it's uh 347 000. when
you when you go to like 9 00 p.m
it's a 169 000 in the key demo so it's a
little bit better than that 10 p.m 134
but hannity is getting half a million
carlson's getting 559 000. the
interesting thing is this is what's
crazy to me is
our numbers are not too far off from
that now that's in one hour
for us in about an hour we are getting
like 150 to 200 000 key demo viewers
this show is rivaling the likes of cnn
i just want to say like be optimistic
yeah we are winning how many
interactions does cnn get zero cause
that's they're not built for it it's an
old media form right and how many people
are passively watching it like and how
many people are taking it seriously and
how many people are watching it just for
the lows and just for the ridiculousness
how many people are trapped in an
airport you know i'm not another hotel
no no hotel hotel lobbies because the
airport thing ended they canceled that
contract do smart tvs measure if like
three people are watching them now have
they figured out how to do that i don't
know but i have to imagine
you know i've i've gone to i've been in
a lot of airports and whenever i would
go in they would have cnn on and i don't
mean like they do these these do this
deal
where the airport tvs are played i mean
like i'll go to a lounge for like the
united lounge or the american lounge and
they would have three tvs and they'd be
playing like cnn and maybe sports and
i'd be like can you turn that off and
they'll be like yeah and they would pop
them out and they would turn it off i'm
like i don't care what you put on just
change channel because that stuff is
mind-melting garbage
and you know what i did favors it's your
key demo number from one night is that
what that is
so
we we actually uh you know tim castillo
gets
we do the two-hour show
and it's it's close to like half a
million in the key demo within two hours
so if we were i don't know
after one hour it's actually like
two-thirds of the views of the first
hour and then it goes down so we're
probably getting like 250 to 300 000 key
demo viewers in one hour and if you look
at that we're
we're half of carlson we're around half
of handy or laura ingram or gutfeld
which makes sense but we're like at or
or or twice as much as what cnn and
msnbc get granted rachel maddow beats us
she got 300 311 000 key demo viewers was
it you that i was shooting this tv be
gone video with a couple years ago we
were we were literally
device that literally was able to turn
off every single television me and tim
went on doing important work by
literally walking around and shutting
off all the corporate media that was in
times square in restaurants in of course
uh you know major bars and entertainment
areas it got tense a couple times when i
had that with me on other occasions when
we weren't filming but uh we literally
made a video of like we gotta save
people and we're gonna use this device
by turning off tvs everywhere we
actually we accidentally turned off the
menu for pizza restaurant i remember
that yeah because when you press it it
just automatically gives all the tv
codes uh signals all at once and turns
it all off but seriously turn off the
programming turn off the conditioning
watching cnn it's nauseating it raises
your blood pressure it's nothing but but
constant low vibrational fear nonsense
crap and it really doesn't serve you in
any way shape or form it doesn't keep
you informed it does the opposite of
that it makes you uh misinformed about
what's really happening in this world i
can't remember what we were talking
about with this but you go to youtube
and you search for a news story like if
you're not going to get a youtuber
you're going to get cnn cbs the crazy
thing is if you search for something on
youtube
that might not be related to news
you'll get news
you search for anything political and
instead of getting information from like
an educational source you'll get cnn
you'll get cbs or pbs it's just weird
and it's fascinating too because their
numbers aren't that great even getting
prioritized by these big tech platforms
i remember facebook had a whole program
it must have been 2015-16 to prop up
reliable news sources and it was like
fox news cnn msnbc and even then they
still weren't getting the engagement and
the reach and the shares that people
like the that the anti-media is getting
not just us but a lot of independent
news organizations and that was being
not only having huge followings but also
being propped up by these institutions
anderson cooper mr vanderbilt had a
special deal with facebook that
literally was making sure that they had
facebook exclusive content available to
everyone shoving it down their throats
shoving it down their algorithms and
they were playing it in my news feed
everyone's news feed and they stopped
that partnership because no one was
watching it no one wants to watch uh
deep state television no one wants to to
watch something that disrespects their
intellect in the basic understanding of
human life and uh i i remember there
used to be a time a few years ago where
i would just have cnn on because they
weren't as sensationalistic they weren't
as bombastic they weren't as crazy but
still back then even a few years ago i
would have it on because they would have
you know good breaking news coverage and
i would i was monitoring the news it was
somewhat okay still kind of low
vibrational but not as bad now i
literally feel sick watching them i
literally feel nauseous and i'm like i
can't this is this is this is absolutely
uh a weaponized
infotainment that's meant to hurt people
in so many extensive ways
terrain theory of disease luke your your
body is mirroring the neurons of the
people you're watching so when you watch
one like brian stelter and he's all
stressed out and hates his life
that you're gonna start your body is
gonna start mimicking that behavior of
stress maybe not necessarily but that's
the theory of like terrain theory of
disease is involved with that and mirror
neurons and things like that i think
absolutely part of if you hear someone
sniffling on the phone when you're
talking to them it might actually make
you sniffle you know because you start
or yawning yawning is another example of
it thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time